how climate lockdowns became the new
Battleground for conspiracy driven
protest movement protesters radicalized
by their opposition to coveted lockdowns
have a new Target
anti-traffic measures so they're already
downplaying what the media themselves
were saying years over the past several
years there was an article in the New
York Times that said the cope because of
the coveted lockdowns the Earth was
healing yes like that was something that
I meant to bring up as like the fact
that like in the beginning of the
coveted lockdown it's like all of the
people that are worried about the
environment were just like ooh you know
rubbing their hands together like this
is our shot if we can get people to lock
down we can save the Earth and I I feel
like
they might have gotten the idea to lock
down and and now actually I'm not going
to say that because they probably had it
long before so that's a bad idea but you
think that the two are connected the
climate and the covid opportunity to
lock people down no I I think that the
the idea for a climate log I was going
to say that or pontificate that the idea
for a climate lockdown might have got
started because of covet but then I
thought about it and they probably had
these plans uh started previous to that
so that's why I didn't want to say it
but yeah I think you know slowing the
rate of carbon dioxide production is
okay but if it's gonna destroy or hinder
Humanity I think that's the wrong tactic
because we can reuse the carbon dioxide
particularly to turn it into graphene
and other materials reuse the methane
also and turn it into carbon dioxide my
problem with those kind of like global
scale
um plans that people have if they mess
up you know you're looking at a a death
toll in the billions you mean if they if
they take too much carbon out of the air
they could pull all the trees and murder
Humanity well I mean I don't I don't
know for sure but like you know Bill
Gates plan to blot out the Sun that is
an actual legit plan that Bill Gates has
been talking like I don't know if
they're talking about uh using something
to seed the clouds and make more clouds
are actually putting some kind of filter
up there to block it he's talked about
it and he's serious I think that's a
terrible idea blocking the amount of sun
that falls on the earth seems like it
only has a bajillion and a half ways
that it can go wrong and kill people
that's the only way to beat the robots
man yeah right yeah you gotta get a
black in the sky bro we don't know if it
was us the robots also plant life uh
relies heavily on sunlight yeah I also
think it's interesting because so many
of these agendas whether it's the world
economic Forum or the United Nations for
some reason they all have seemed to
identify the year 2030 as like their end
goal 2013 or 2030 and even the weft has
their own sort of like iteration of it
that also concludes in 2030. China has
their 2030 plan too they also have a
2025 one but I think it'll be really
interesting that's why I think this
election really is so pivotal because I
think the world not just America will
take two very different trajectories
right if you have someone like Donald
Trump in office I would argue that
agenda 2030 is not going to just get you
know carte blanche blank sign off by
Donald Trump to enforce it whereas if
you have someone like Joe Biden who
empirically throughout you know the
United Nations and the who pandemic
treaty his actions have shown that he's
sort of on board with that and a lot of
his advisors are too I think you will
see two very very different outcomes for
the world writ large depending on who
wins this this election site
really think that even if like someone
and I don't really have a I don't really
care if it's Donald Trump or someone
else but if it is Donald Trump like I
don't think that it's like a guarantee
that he can navigate us through the you
know the coming tumultuous situation of
you know the wef trying to take over the
world I think that Donald Trump is just
a maybe if we go to the Democrat it's a
definite that we're going to do whatever
it is that the International Community
wants we lose our sovereignty if we if
we elect a Democrat because they don't
in they don't push back against the
International Community so whatever the
International Community wants is what
the what the United States does
regardless of what the American people
want let me let me pull this up from
Wikipedia just so you understand agenda
2030. this is from Wikipedia sustainable
development goals from the UN
they say it's uh they're Global goals or
sustainable development goals or
collection of 17 interlinked objectives
designed to serve as a shared blueprint
for peace and prosperity 17 is a magic
number dreaming James Lindsay says too
oh yeah for people and the planet now
into the future they say it was
formulated in 2015 by the UN General
Assembly as part of the post 2015
development agenda they say they were
formally articulated and adopted in a
unga resolution called the 2030 agenda
known colloquially as agenda 2030. so
when you hear people saying this you're
going to get the media saying it's one
big conspiracy theory it's all nonsense
and what they're going to do is
they're going to ignore the actual
complaints people have about the the
mission of the UN and they'll hyper
focus on some random crackpot in an
alley who's screaming that agenda 2030
is trying to steal moon cheese and
they'll be like these crazy conspiracy
theorists think the Earth is flat and
then the average person who's like hey
this is a bit alarming to me because
we're a Sovereign Nation that shouldn't
be giving over our rights to an
international body they will omit that
from the news reports that's the same
same type of thing that they did with
the whole like Jeffrey Epstein stuff and
then the pizza place like they've
they've used the crazy guy going to the
pizza place to to deflect from like
Epstein actually getting arrested and
going and and the trial at you know and
him actually being found guilty of of
human trafficking and stuff they were
using the pizza gate stuff to discredit
the idea that there were actually right
you know and everyone knows that Epstein
had been you know found guilty of of uh
trafficking that gives Lane
found yeah he got some deal but early on
yeah but uh but everyone knows that that
was the situation they everyone knows
that there have been no names released
and yet people still will say things
like oh Pizza gate you know you're
thinking that it's kind of crazy to
think that there are people in the
government that are pedophiles there's
multiple court cases that have been
found that these people did wasn't like
prince Andrew directly implicated prince
Andrew couldn't wear certain clothing at
the funeral of the queen because of his
embarrassing the royal family like he
couldn't wear his official Cape or
something like that I think it was
military dress I'm not sure what the
what it was but there was official stuff
that that uh that the prince should have
been able to wear ceremonial yeah
disgrace them look at this goal number
one is no poverty
how that's not possible yeah good luck
poverty is relative a poor person today
has better Dental Care than Rockefeller
did 100 years ago 100 and some odd years
ago so that's like it's an impossible
thing to say zero hunger Let's uh hold
on hold on let me let me tell you I'm
supposed to be hungry sometimes I know
my Hunger is a good thing it tells you
that you need to put food in yourself
right uh let's I'm going to approach
this from the view of Ultron the Rogue
AI that was trying to wipe out Humanity
how do you end poverty they say goal
number one is to end poverty in all its
forms everywhere
it would end poverty globally one of its
indicators is the proportion of
population living before the below the
poverty line now you see these these
these lefties and these corporate
journalists or whatever might see that
and say oh I get it if they give all the
poor people more access and money
they'll be above the poverty line and
then all of the international rates look
at each other like uh sure and what
they're actually envisioning is the
poverty line is the cutoff point where
they excise that portion of the
population and then there's no poor
people anymore then they say zero hunger
same thing how do you get rid of hunger
anyone who's hungry gotta go you know
what I'm saying good health and
well-being anyone who's not gotta go
quality education once again those who
are not getting quality education you
gotta go and wait where are you going
anyone that says that about getting rid
of people that are in good health look
at what Canada is doing now with maid
like when you first when you first hear
it you think oh it would never happen
but if you think real quick oh wait a
minute it's literally happening in
Canada they were they're encouraging
people people that are a burden to the
system to kill themselves this is not
far-fetched this is not imaginary this
is exactly what a lot of the ngos want
to see happen the the idea that Nations
should end and we should be a global
community in a global country or
whatever you want I got to be honest
like if you were to look through this
population reduction does seem to be a
general path towards acquire
accomplishing a lot of these goals
absolutely think about this how do you
get rid of poverty well if we have
mechanization and Automation and you
remove a large portion of the population
through mate or whatever or through even
even if growth degrowth like this is the
thing people don't understand about this
they assume and the media would want you
to assume that the conspiracy there's a
conspiracy theory where the global leads
are going to go around killing people
it's like okay well maybe with medical
assistance and dying and death or
whatever up in Canada you have something
like that but it's really just like
don't have kids abort your kids
sterilize your kids take birth control
that's degrowth that is one way to
achieve the goal it's um
did you guys ever play we talked about
this before Fallout oh yeah I can't
remember which one it was but the in the
end one of the endings is for those that
aren't familiar it's a post-apocalyptic
World wiped out by nukes there's a
gigantic super intelligent mutant being
who says you can choose to I'll let you
go and you can live but you have to be
sterilized so that you can't reproduce
anymore because you're you're old world
or something that affects us the first
one yeah I think so so the general idea
is no no you're mistaken no one wants to
reduce population they just don't want
you to have kids and then in 20 30 years
population will have been reduced tell
me about D growth D growth is is
essentially
so the way that the the argument goes is
our capitalist Society depends on
infinite growth right it has to keep
growing because we keep having more
people we have to keep producing and we
live on a finite Earth we live on earth
with a a cert with a limited amount of
resources and we are going to use them
up so what we need to do is not we have
to have a net zero impact on the
environment so that means we don't have
an impact Net Zero means a totally zero
impact on the environment and you're
going to achieve that through degrowth
which means you have to have a
contraction of the economies of the
countries on the on the planet
it your GDP is directly related to your
life expectancy every point of GDP that
your country goes down there is a
corresponding number of deaths that
happen so D growth means population
shrinking they and that is intentional
now it starts off and this is and I'm
looking back to the first half of the
20th century Eugenics and population
control and these types of man
controlling Society with big plans like
like they're talking about here these
these type of programs will start off
with one mandate and one one idea and
they and they grow and I hate to do this
because I don't want people to be like
oh you know everyone Compares it but
like the stuff that Hitler did to the
Jews in Nazi Germany didn't start off
with grab them and throw them into the
uh into the concentration camps started
with okay you gotta wear these patches
it starts small so the idea of we have
to do things to contract the government
has to do things to contract they will
start small and as it doesn't work as
fast as they want and as there are
people that will push back they will
continue to up their efforts and you
will end up with I imagine billions debt
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time